حلف الناتو يخون أوكرانيا
على مرأى ومسمع
ويزيد أوجاع الأوكرانيين.
ومحاولة اغتيال الرئيس الأوكراني
تدب الرعب في الوسط الغربي،
وبايدن يكررها للمرة الثالثة
أنه لن يخوض حربا ضد موسكو.
الضربات تتوالى على كييف من العدو الصديق
.روسيا تستعد لاستخدام أحد أقوى الأسلحة في العالم،
والمفاجأة أن هذا السلاح ليس سلاحا نوويا،
والدمار والفناء يقترب أكثر فأكثر من أوكرانيا،،
وزيلنسكي يعود للظهور مجددا،
وبين هذا وذاك مساعٍ حثيثة لمفاوضات
وقف الحرب، وعقوبات لن تؤتي أكلها
في القريب العاجل، ووعود لا تسمن
ولا تغني من جوع، والمواجهات على أشدها
محدثة توترا غير مسبوق، ومصير أوكرانيا
لم يعد بيدها اليوم، ...
الناتو والغرب يضعون طعنة من الخلف
في ظهر أوكرانيا!!!
الأمين العام لحلف شمال  الأطلسي قال:
الناتو حلف دفاعي ولا يسعى للصراع مع روسيا
،، إذا لماذا غرر الحلف بأوكرانيا لتقاتل
إحدى أقوى دولتين في العالم ثم تركها لوحدها هكذا؟
هو استمرار لقتال الحلف ضد أعدائه
لكن بالوكالة يا أصدقائي!!..
إحباط محاولة لاغتيال الرئيس الأوكراني
فولوديمير زيلينسكي على أيدي مجموعة شيشانية،
وتم تأكيد الخبر  في كييف وليس الرئيس فقط
من حاولوا اغتياله بل جميع أعضاء الحكومة
في تصعيد قد يغير موازين الحرب لو نجحت العملية...
ارتفاع وتيرة المواجهات بين جيشي روسيا وأوكرانيا
وسط اقتراب المعارك من حرب المدن،
وتعزيزات كبيرة للجيش الروسي
دفع بها بوتين باتجاه العاصمة الأوكرانية كييف،
مع اندلاع معارك طاحنة بين الطرفين،
والقصف الروسي يستهدف محطات الطاقة في خاركيف،
كل ذلك تبينه المخاوف الغربية
من استخدام روسيا لأسلحتها الحرارية،
فما هي هذه الأسلحة الخطيرة؟
هو أقوى سلاح غير نووي بالعالم،
وهو الذي تحركه موسكو باتجاه أوكرانيا اليوم،
هل سمعتم يوما بسلاح يبخر الأجساد البشرية؟،
ويمتص الأجسام من الرئتين ويشعل الهواء؟،
إنه (الصاروخ الحراري، أو ما يطلق عليه
القنبلة الفراغية)
المعروفة بأم القنابل، تملكها روسيا،
وقد شوهدت والجيش الروسي يحركها
باتجاه أوكرانيا، وتعرف ب (قاذفات اللهب)
و(سلاح الشمس الحارقة) وهو تطوير للمصطلح
الروسي القديم (الأرض المحروقة)
القاذفة الروسية توس١، وهي آلة عسكرية
مجنزرة فوقها راجمة صواريخ،
يجري توجيهها بالأشعة تحت الحمراء،
(زيلينسكي على الشاشة)
الرئيس الأوكراني يلقي كلمة مسجلة
على البرلمان الأوروبي..
مساع أوروبية لتكثيف العقوبات على روسيا
لوقف الحرب،... وقال زيلينسكي:
أنه سيتنصر وسط تصفيق لعدة دقائق
في جلسة طارئة لمشروع قرار يدين روسيا،
وأضاف زيلينسكي، (دوبلاج) إن "الاتحاد الأوروبي
سيكون أقوى بكثير معنا، هذا أمر مؤكد.
بدونكم، ستكون أوكرانيا وحيدة".
وأضاف: "أثبتوا أنكم معنا، وأثبتوا أنكم لن تسمحوا لنا
بالرحيل، وأثبتوا أنكم أوروبيون حقاً،
ومن ثم ستنتصر الحياة على الموت،
وسينتصر النور على الظلام. المجد لأوكرانيا".
بينما أعلن الجيش الروسي سيطرته الكاملة
على مدينة خريسون جنوب أوكرانيا،
(التطورات والأحداث)
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني جونسن يقول(دوبلاج)،
أنا مقتنع بفشل بوتين وأن بوتين سيفشل
وأن بوتين يجب أن يفشل ،
وأننا سننجح في حماية والحفاظ على ديمقراطية
واستقلال أوكرانيا،..
البرلمان الأوروبي على لسان رئيسته،
يقول أنه فرض العقوبات وسيفرض المزيد منها
بشكل غير مسبوق على روسيا، وأنه سيقدم
دعم لا متناهي من الأسلحة لأوكرانيا،
وسط مطالبات في الاتحاد الأوروبي بمقاطعة
الاعتماد على الغاز الروسي، كجزء من العقوبات،
وتجهيز ملفات لتقديمها للمحكمة الدولية،
عن ارتكاب روسيا لجرائم حرب في أوكرانيا،
....
الرئيس الأمريكي جو بايدن
سنعمل مع ٣٠ دولة حول العالم
على سحب ٣٠مليون برميل نفط من الاحتياطي
كجزء من القرارات التي اتخذناها للوقوف بحزم
ضد الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا،
وسنعمل على المزيد كلما احتجنا لذلك،،،
بايدن قال أيضا،
إن بوتين ديكتاتور شن حربا غير مبررة،
وأعدُ بزيادة العقوبات على روسيا لحرمان بوتين
من تمويل آلاته العسكرية
خلال ذلك أعلن بايدن أيضا انضمام بلاده
بإغلاق كامل لمجالاتها الجوية أمام الخطوط
الجوية الروسية، كما فعلت معظم الدول الغربية، ..
لكن مع كل ذلك التهديد أكد بايدن أن جنوده
لن يخوضوا حربا ضد روسيا مكررا حديثة
للمرة الثالثة..
القوات الانفصالية في دونيتسك،
ستنظم ممرين إنسانيين لخروج آمن
لسكان ماريوبول..
في الوقت الذي أعلن فيه زيلنسكي :
مقتل حوالي 6 آلاف روسي خلال ستة أيام
من الحرب، مطالباً بدعم ضم أوكرانيا للاتحاد الأوروبي،
قائلاً: لم يعد هناك وقت للحياد..
وصور لمدنيين أوكران يضعون أنفسهم
كحواجز بشرية أمام دبابات ومدرعات الجيش الروسي
لمنعهم من دخول مدينتهم،
تهديد خطير لخريطة الطيران العالمية،
بعد أن اتسعت رقعة الحظر عن الطيران فوق روسيا
وأوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا، بسبب الحظر الجوي
الذي فرضته أوروبا أمام الخطوط الجوية الروسية،
في جزء من العقوبات للضغط أكثر على روسيا
لإيقاف الحرب..
٣٦ دولة أوروبية وغربية في قائمة الدول التي
أعلنت الحظر الجوي ضد روسيا في المقابل
فعلت موسكو الشىء ذاته وحظرت تلك الدول أيضا...
زيلينسكي اليهودي عاد ليستعطف اليهود
أن لا يلتزموا الصمت حيال الحرب على بلاده،،
ألا ترى ي هذا أنك تخاطب اليهود
الذين يرتكبون بالمسلمين جرائم بشعة أكثر
مما يعمله الروس بكم، هل هذه هي الحرية
والديمقراطية لديكم؟ بئس ما